se una musa di fuoco
crescesse la nostra
il punto accrescesse no no no limitasse
la vostra fantasia
al punto da farvi sembrare una metropoli
affollata una stanza dei personaggi
eroici degli attori mingherlini fermi
impalati immaginate dunque che
sconfinate foreste siano semplici pareti
per mille uomini che vedete sullo
schermo immaginate nella metà di una
dozzina pensate quando sentirete
pronunciare infuocate parole d'amore che
un microfono è stato il nostro
interlocutore
la vostra mente non si inganni vedendo
sulla scena il sole che illumina il
paesaggio
noi abbiamo recitato al buio soli in una
sala di doppiaggio il doppiaggio e così
ho descritto il nostro dietro le quinte
il doppiaggio la lingua parlata dagli
italiani
no non era così che diceva flaiano
diceva l'italiano la lingua parlata dai
doppiatori anche se un po di
responsabilità nell'aver imbastardito la
nostra bella lingua il doppiaggio ce le
ha
la lingua la parola il verbo io continua
con citazioni importanti
sono un solo popolo hanno una sola
lingua e ora nessun progetto sarà per
loro impossibile da realizzare
scendiamo e confondiamo la loro lingua
così che non capiscano più l'uno la
lingua dell'altro
adesso vi invito a immaginare quella
confusione improvvisa quel brusio
assordante nel quale le parole hanno
perso ogni significato
la sola cosa che accomuna tutti è lo
stato d'animo la paura e lo smarrimento
lo sconforto la rabbia e la
rassegnazione e poi ancora il coraggio
la passione l'amore le emozioni insomma
le emozioni non hanno bisogno di essere
tradotte e non mentono e ci accomunano
tutti lo stiamo percependo in questo
periodo in modo chiaro e io già mi
aspetto di vedere presto mi auguro i
frutti cinematografici e televisivi che
le strane emozioni di questo strano
periodo avranno maturato anzi faccio un
salto nel futuro mi vedo arrivare in una
sala di doppiaggio a doppiare un film
che racconta proprio la storia d'amore
dopo di due amanti che si vedono dopo la
quarantena avrei io arrivo tutta
trafelata in sala di doppiaggio arrivo
al turno e mi cominciano a dire allora
questo è il ruolo questo è il tuo
personaggio questa bella attrice
bellissima perché in genere sono sempre
bellissime
l'uomo arriva la scena si svolge
partiamo dalla fine tanto per te non
cambia niente no no va bene non cambia
niente
partiamo dalla fine lui arriva in un
trascinati dalla passione in un fiume di
parole si scambiano baci tenerezze a
bracce si confermano il loro amore dopo
mesi che non si vedono
vedo la scena sono pronte a doppiarla no
non sono pronta i baci devo farli no
chiara i baci ci sono e questa è ora vi
spiego il senso del titolo
la domanda più frequente che un attore
fa al fonico e proprio se ci sono in
baci cioè se questo rumore c'è nella
colonna musica effetti che non si tocca
forse dobbiamo farlo noi e allora vi
rendete conto che l'aspetto tecnico del
nostro lavoro ci rende dei virtuosi dei
veri e propri funamboli giocolieri della
parola che incastona mothra un fià
dell'altro da fare da non fare traversi
pianti i risate e tutto questo è scritto
sul copione tanto da far somigliare il
copione nel doppiaggio in sala più a uno
spartito musicale che non ha un testo
cinematografico o teatrale nei nostri
copioni sono indicate le pause gli
attacchi di battuta
i toni se va sussurrata va detto piano
piano si va strillata o come un forte un
fortissimo
solo che a differenza di un musicista
noi non abbiamo il tempo di studiare
prima la partitura nel rivedere
interamente il film in un certo senso
noi dobbiamo improvvisare e l'emozione
dello spettatore
il primo spettatore siamo è molto facile
si viene d'aiuto cioè si affacci
facilita il compito però attenzione non
deve essere la mia personale emozione da
spettatore deve essere quella di chi ha
creato quel progetto quella di chi ha
immaginato per primo il personaggio e le
sue intenzioni
noi siamo degli spettatori interpreti
facciamo da tramite traghettiamo
intenzioni partecipando in modo concreto
al processo ricreativo dell'opera
abbiamo un obbligo ricreare l'opera con
sincerità senza voler esprimere la
nostra personalità
anzi addirittura annullandola è chiaro
che per annullare la propria personalità
bisogna almeno averne una e come si dice
avere la stoffa e poi sarà allo studio
la dedizione
l'esperienza saranno le mani del sarto
che faranno in modo che
potremmo poi creare l'abito che
desideriamo e come per tutti gli
artigiani sta proprio nel far apprezzare
la propria opera
l'abilità dell'artigiano sta proprio nel
far apprezzare la propria opera senza
far cogliere il lavoro che ci è voluto
per realizzarla così un buon doppiaggio
è proprio quello di cui non ci si
accorge e la libertà che ci è concessa
sembra pochissima è proprio quella di
non dover piacere a noi stessi di non
doverci appoggiare alla nostra bella
voce ma piuttosto di asservirla
totalmente al personaggio e nella mia
carriera posso dire che questa è proprio
una delle doti che mi hanno permesso di
doppiare tante attrici importanti in
film altrettanto importanti perché non
vi si riconosce
la più grande qualità a un doppiato
tante protagoniste scomparendo dentro di
loro cercando di ritrovare re
interpretare il ruolo in un equilibrio
tra tecnica ed emozione nel rispetto del
pubblico come obiettivo finale per
esempio uno dei film ai quali sono più
legata ai ruoli anche mi ricordo
l'emozione che non prova in sala dove si
provava emozione da spettatrice ma
l'emozione di scoprire la chiave per
interpretare quel ruolo sto parlando di
un film di lars von trier e le orme del
destino l'attrice emily watson e non
riuscivo a trovare il modo per doppiare
questo personaggio strano che in quegli
anni non si capiva bene forse oggi
diremmo che nello spettro autistico una
lieve forma di forma di autismo e quindi
era curiosa da a doppiare e non trovavo
la chiave
andavo a cinecittà a doppiarla e facendo
questo percorso e metropolitano ho visto
una mamma con un bambino e questo
pubblico a un certo punto mi ricordava
qualcuno e poi come mi si è accesa una
lampadina mi ricordava best mcneal il
personaggio
allora ho capito che la chiave era
essere una bambina anche se è quello che
viveva non era da bambina viveva ad una
storia da donna importante però era la
chiave era trovare quell emozione lì e
lì mi sono emozionata e qui mi sono
portata dietro questa emozione per tutto
il film un film in cui tutti si sono
emozionati il titanic
noi l'abbiamo gestita così l'emozione
pur sapendo benissimo la storia del
titanic la storia privata dei personaggi
di rose e jack non lo sapevamo e il
direttore tonino accolla ci ha lasciati
nel non sapevamo come sarebbe andata a
finire
e quindi ci ha permesso di usare
l'emozione della rivelazione di quello
che stava accadendo in modo molto utile
perché l'emozione c'è un po saliva
saliva come l'acqua della nave fino a
sommergersi totalmente ed è stata un
modo per mantenerla sempre viva questa
freschezza sempre kate winslet mi
ricordo un film in cui non ho capito
niente se mi lasci ti cancello mentre lo
facevo non capivo niente
del film e non trovavo una chiave poi
c'è stata una scena in cui i personaggi
erano senza volto allora ho capito che
forse lasciarmi andare a non volere
spiegazioni non volerci mettere il
cervello a tutti i costi ma lasciare che
non ci fosse memoria neanche di un volto
poteva essere questa la chiave ogni
battuta nasceva fresca come se non ci
fosse un passato e quella era la chiave
un'altra esperienza con nicole kidman
primo film che ho doppiato andai a fare
il provino su di lei e avevo un
abbassamento vocale lo sai come un
ostacolo utile per una tecnica ormai già
affinata per sfruttare queste note così
poco
così incorporee così lievi lo vinsi il
provino perché il personaggio era
incorporeo sto parlando di the others e
sono tante le situazioni in cui questo
gioco mi è riuscito e si è compiuto
l'incanto del doppiaggio e quando questo
viene allora diventano vere le parole
con le quali voglio salutarvi di nelson
mandela lui di qui ha detto che parlare
a qualcuno in una lingua che comprende
con consente di raggiungere il suo
cervello parlargli nella sua lingua
madre
significa raggiungere il suo cuore